Disney they've heard you you know Disney
they got a little blowback when they
were caught on camera saying that they
were pushing a Noto secret gay agenda on
your children Disney got a little bit of
push back when they replaced Snow White
with this woman in a a new Snow White
story who uh she she emphatically you
know isn't Snow White we I call her
sometimes like um sand beige or
something like that but that that's not
that's by by far the least silly part of
her Casting the silliest part of her
Casting is she
hates the story and she says we don't
want love we don't want a prince
charming we don't want this we don't
want it's obviously so woke it was
obviously Dei it was obviously you know
any kind of
traditional traditional is bad white is
bad men are bad though in that case it's
a it's a female character being replaced
by a female but now we've got a better
opportunity for Disney they've heard you
so they're going to replace Johnny Depp
with a black lady according to reports
uh the lady is IO
edir um I don't I'm not familiar with
her work she might be a fine actress but
one thing I can tell you is she's not
the Johnny Depp character because she's
not a
dude and and this would be for Pirates
of the Caribbean
six uh her character is named
an so it's not an exact onetoone of
Captain Jack Sparrow uh it's this new
character named an and it might be based
off a real life pirate named Anne Bonnie
who was Irish so what Disney's pushing
back and they're saying look we want to
replace all the white guys with black
ladies in the name of Dei even if it
doesn't serve the story even if it
doesn't make sense but you you racists
and you sexists you don't even
understand this is based on a real
character and the real character is a
woman well that's true but the woman's
Irish and I don't I don't think this is
what Black Irish means have you ever
heard that phrase black Black Irish
Black Irish is a term used among Irish
Americans to explain why certain Irish
people here have slightly darker
features or dark hair or dark eyes but
it's totally made up this the the myth
around Black Irish is that some
Spaniards landed in Ireland some
centuries ago and that's why some of
them look a little bit more
Mediterranean uh but it it doesn't
appear to be backed up by any genetic
analyses so it's just it's just a fake
American kind of story and in any case
uh Black Irish doesn't mean actual like
afan people now you might say well
Michael who cares any any person of any
race or some would say of of any sex
should be able to play any
character uh I don't think that's true
I'm some characters I think the race
doesn't really matter all characters the
sex usually matters but some the race
doesn't really matter but that view was
not the view of August Wilson the leader
of the modern American black theater
that wasn't the view of of a whole lot
of people in the history of
theater and it isn't the view of
audiences like
some Sexes are different cultures are
different
and every time that Disney does this the
movies are
flops but they don't really care they
feel that they have hegemony so they're
going to they're going to serve it up
and doesn't matter go see it don't go
see it the Dei leftist agenda continues
a pace right now go to to woke tarwater
decom seems like wokeism is everywhere
it's in the air we breathe the news we
watch even in the water we drink that is
why woke tears bottled water an American
brand is on a mission to save America
from the brave new woke world one sip at
a time woke teers water is a legitimate
brand of drinking water bottled right
here in the US by people who know what a
woman is made from Pure snowflake
meltdowns woke tier's water is making
hydration great again while everyone
everyone else's water is just water woke
tears provides a refreshing gulp of
laughter in a world thirsty for sanity
if you want to try woke Tew water visit
woke Tew water.com indulge today in
laughter and hydration two of the most
important things in your life right now
go to woke tarwater decom today I love
that this is clearly taken some
inspiration from our famous Tumblr great
great thing to be sipping around the
office woke tears water
now speaking of women potentially
replacing men the Nevada presidential
primary took place most people didn't
pay attention to it because the
Republican primary is effectively over
and Trump is the nominee but what was
weird about Nevada is that Nevada had
both a primary and a
caucus so in Nevada it used to be that
the nomination fight was settled in a
caucus and then in 2021 the legislature
said no we're going to become a primary
State not a caucus state but the GOP
didn't like this so the GOP has held
firm to the caucus they had a separate
caucus and they said that if you
participate in the primary you don't get
to participate in the caucus so even
before all the other candidates dropped
out all most of them were going to
participate in the caucus Nikki Haley
was not Nikki Haley said no I'm going to
be in the
primary and so as a result Trump who is
the last remaining serious candidate in
the primary he was not in the Nevada
Republican presidential primary he won
the Nevada caucus which is actually
what's going to count toward the
nomination and Nikki Haley won the
Primary well no she didn't she beat Mike
Pence who was still on the ballot even
though he dropped out she beat Tim Scott
who was still on the ballot even though
he dropped out she beat John Castro who
I've never heard of even though he was
still on the ballot but she
lost to none of these
candidates Nikki got about
33% and none of these candidates got
60.4%
% none of these candidates got almost
twice as many votes as Nikki
Haley not a good sign now Nikki did not
really campaign in Nevada obviously she
wasn't even taking the primary seriously
that's why she wasn't in the
caucus but it's it's embarrassing it's
not it's not a good headline cycle now
they're headed to South Carolina and the
problem with South Carolina is Trump is
currently leading Nikki by at least 20
points depends which poll you look at
but maybe 30 points maybe more that's
her home state so as I've predicted for
a while Nikki is going to stay in this
race and she she said it she said I'm
not going anywhere keep donating uh
she's going to stay in this race to be
the number two candidate to be the clear
number two once Trump gets a nomination
and then in 2028 she'll be able to claim
look I was I was the last choice if
Trump loses she can claim head you're
going with me maybe you would have won
and if even if Trump wins he's going to
be term limited out so she can she can
say look I was the number two Choice
then and she can make a credible run in
2028 and she can claim to represent the
lane that she's picked which is the more
establishment more Centrist kind of Lane
in the GOP which still represents a lot
of Voters and you can say I've got
appeal to Independence and I've got
appeal to Suburban moms and all all this
kind of stuff but one thing that is
certain is that she will not be the
Republican nominee in
2024 now another reason that Nikki Haley
is running here is because one she a
talented politician and she's managed to
beat out all the other candidates in the
field other than Trump and two because
Biden seems so
beatable I think it was Peter Ducey who
just asked White House Press Secretary
Ken jeanpierre if she could maybe
explain uh why Joe Biden thought that he
had just met with the former president
of France who died in
1996 here is K JP's answer how is
President Biden ever going to convince
the three4 of Voters who are worried
about his physical and mental health
that he is okay even though in Las Vegas
he told a story about recently talking
to a French president who died in
1996 I'm not even going to go down that
rabbit hole with you sir Rabbit Hole he
said he talked to Minon you saw the
president in Vegas in California you've
seen the president in South Carolina you
saw him in M Michigan I'll just leave it
there what listen I'm not even go I'm
not even GNA answer your question which
is the best answer she could give
there's no way to explain the the the
honest answer is because Joe Biden's
obviously in Decline and he's doing that
thing that your grandparents all did
just before they died which is they
confused people and they confused not
not just weeks and years but they
confused whole decades and epochs and
they forgot who's alive and who's dead
that's the honest answer so she can't
say that she goes I'm not even going to
answer that question then he goes what
are you what are you talking about your
job is to answer the questions give it
and her the best she can must is look
you've seen the president California
Alaska
Brazil China I had eggs for breakfast
this morning look at my hand is that a
butterfly gble goab okay next question
that's the best thing she just she's
just going to say words so
that maybe if you put the TV on mute it
looks like she's answering the question
but her her firm answer is yeah man we
got nothing we we've got
nothing as it pertains to a rational
debate over Joe Biden's uh case for
reelection we got nothing there the best
they're going to hope for is that they
can keep rigging the the elections with
uh losing voter ID with promoting
widespread mail in ballots and with
encouraging ballot harvesting that's
their only chance and maybe they think
it's a good chance and they don't think
they have to answer to the people what a
great clip that was now hey hey hey hey
come on Jack come on man Corn Pop ring
that Bell we'll see you next time